humans have existed for millions of
years as part of nature but then
something changed and in an incredibly
short amount of time we terraformed this
planet and designed it to fit our needs
as far as we know with the first beings
to awaken and completely take over a
planet with the transition from hunting
and gathering to farming and building
was so breathtakingly fast that many of
our ways of thinking about the world are
no longer useful one of our most
outdated ideas is that the most commonly
used calendar in the world insists that
we live in the year 2016
this distorts our view of our own
history and makes it harder to
understand who we are as a species and
just how far we've come in an incredibly
short amount of time so maybe it's time
to choose a year zero for Humanity a
year zero that truly represents us as a
species and includes all cultures a year
zero that marks when we began building
our own world on top of the old one
[Music]
12,000 years ago hundreds of humans came
together in the hills of southern
Anatolia they were hunters and gatherers
without knowledge of Agriculture or
metalworking all they had were tools
made of stone and wood but they built
humanity's first big construction
project seven thousand years before the
pyramids were built in Egypt spread over
three hundred meters our ancestors
erected circles of massive stone pillars
each of them up to six metres high and
40 tons in weight decorated with artful
pictograms and stone carvings of animals
and mythical creatures we have no idea
how they were able to do this it was
probably a project of epic scale for the
Stone Age requiring a level of
organization we didn't know early humans
were capable of until we found this site
so why did they build it the most
popular theory is that this was the
first temple of humanity dedicated to
long-forgotten gods we only know that
this construction project the first of
its kind marks the beginning of a new
era
it's in this area around that time that
humans truly began to build their own
world which would make it a fitting
milestone in our history for the start
of our calendar this moment in time is
so distinct that scientist Cesare
emiliana proposed that humanity should
switch to what he called the Holocene
calendar by adding 10,000 years to our
current Gregorian calendar we don't need
to change our well-established days and
months and religious calendars could
stay the same as well but for all
official purposes our current year would
be the year 12,000 and 16 of the human
era this would drastically alter how we
think about history and how it feels
let's take a very brief look and move
through our new history from our New
Year Zero 12,000 years ago saw the
beginning of the first construction
project kicking off our history it would
be in use for about 2,000 years it took
nearly a millennium until Jericho
probably the first city on earth was
founded in the year 1000 after the start
of the human era progress was still very
very slow at this point over the next
thousand years more and more permanent
settlements appeared around the world
and more and more plants and animals
were domesticated as agriculture spread
evidence for trade over thousands of
kilometres has been found from this
period around five million humans were
alive at this point in history fewer
than live in London today technology
advanced constantly at a slow pace
pottery became widespread the first
cultural communities appeared in China
India and
Fertile Crescent around the Year 4,000
8,000 years ago from today humans
started to use metal for the first time
learning to mix tin and copper and
kick-starting what we know as the Bronze
Age around the Year 5000 the first
proto-writing emerged and the wheel was
invented in South America the Chinchorro
culture started to artificially mummify
humans 2,000 years earlier than in
ancient Egypt the first high cultures
began emerging around the Year 7000 the
Indus Valley Civilisation ancient Egypt
the Minoans in Greece and the Sumerians
in Mesopotamia Stonehenge was built in
Britain and the first dynasty in China
began let's see the IceMen lived around
this time what we consider history now
started and things began picking up pace
as the world population rose to over 30
million a number of new high cultures
appeared around the world many writing
down their legends more and more cities
were founded in South America the Olmec
culture emerged around this time the
legendary siege of Troy is supposed to
have happened soon after in the eastern
Mediterranean and the Fertile Crescent
the Bronze Age ended in violence every
Bronze Age culture except Egypt was
destroyed by mysterious invaders rioting
and progressive froze for hundreds of
years around the Year 9500 what we
consider Western culture began the Greek
city-states beat off the Persian
invasion and triggered their golden era
ended by Alexander the Great around 9700
one hundred years later
Rodan destroyed Carthage and became a
dominant force in the world Caesar was
murdered in the year nine thousand nine
hundred and fifty-six while the world
population had risen to about 300
million people
and it's only now around the Year 10,000
that we've reached the point where the
Gregorian calendar and our current
method of marking human history begins a
mere 2,000 years from now humans will
walk on the moon if we think about
history as we do now we are under
playing 10,000 years of human progress
and development including all of it in
our calendar makes our past more
impressive
it shows how progress became exponential
with time and it incorporates all humans
from all cultures into our calendar a
new year zero for our history could
reframe how we think of ourselves as a
building project that started 12,000
years ago when for the first time our
ancestors came together to carve a
temple out of bedrock with tools made of
stone not knowing what they would set in
motion where it would lead us as a
species from building the first temple
to ships flying beyond the sky
we've made eight cuts cause after
version of the human error calendar that
you can buy here if you want it's a
calendar for 2017
but with one important difference it's
for the year twelve thousand and
seventeen the year we think we should be
in right now there are only a very
limited amount available but if we sell
enough of them we'll make this a regular
thing and maybe produce more print
products in the future the calendar is
illustrated and we put in a few fun
facts also as always if you like what we
do please consider supporting us on
patreon for buying things we made it
really helps thanks and have a happy
twelve thousand and seventeen